THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
THE FOGGY WEATHER HELD OFF AND
THE SUN BROKE THROUGH HERE IN
LONDON AS PRESIDENT TRUMP KICKED
OFF THE THREE-DAY STATE VISIT TO
ONE OF AMERICA'S OLDEST AND
STRONGEST ALLIES.
THE POMP & CIRCUMSTANCE THAT
ONLY THE BRITISH MONARCHY CAN
SUMMON IS TRULY A SIGHT TO
BEHOLD.
THE FACT THAT THINGS WENT SO
SMOOTHLY CLEARLY IRRITATED THE
MEDIA ELITE AT HOME AND ABROAD.
>> THE OCCASION INVOLVES A LOT
OF TRADITION, INTERESTING FOR A
PRESIDENT WHO I THINK IT'S FAIR
TO SAY IS ANYTHING BUT
TRADITIONAL.
>> SO MUCH OF ANY STATE VISIT IS
POMP AND CEREMONY.
LET'S BE HONEST, THAT'S WHAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP LIKES.
>> SO MUCH IS IN THE PICTURE.
IT'S NOT INSIGNIFICANT FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP IN MANY WAYS YOU
MIGHT THINK, THE BEST BET IS TO
SAY VERY LITTLE AND LET THE
PICTURES SPEAK FOR THEMSELVES.
>> Laura: INDEED, MANY
ANTI-TRUMP MEDIA ELITES, THEY
SEEMED DISAPPOINTED THAT THE
PROTESTS TODAY -- WE WERE OUT
AND ABOUT, WERE SO TINY.
>> IT WILL BE INTERESTING TO SEE
HOW LARGE THE PROTESTS ARE.
>> TOMORROW THE PRESIDENT HAS A
SERIES OF EVENTS WITH THERESA
MAYE.
THAT'S WHEN WE EXPECT THE
PROTESTS.
>> A WHOLE LOAD OF PROTESTS
PLANNED.
THAT COMES TOMORROW.
>> THE PROPROTESTS, THEY EXPECT
TO BE BIGGER TOMORROW.
>> THE PRESIDENT IT SEEMS HAS
AVOIDED SEEING PROTESTS.
>> TOMORROW, 2RU6R
>> TOMORROW, TRU6R
>> TOMORROW, TRUMR
>> TOMORROW, TRUMP MAKING
ANOTHER APPEARANCE BETWEEN 9:00
A.M. AND 11:00 A.M.
>> Laura: TOMORROW LIKE
CHRISTMAS FOR THEM.
TODAY, NOT SO MUCH.
OF COURSE, THE LAZIES IN THE
LAME STREAM MEDIA, THEY LOVE
SUCKING UP TO ANY TRUMP CRITIC
ON FOREIGN SOIL.
THEY DID THE SAME, REMEMBER TO
REAGAN IN THE '80s AND BUSH IN
THE EARLY 2000s.
LONDON MAYOR SADIQ KHAN WAS
CITED FOR WRITING AN OP-ED
WELCOMING THE PRESIDENT THIS
WAY.
DONALD TRUMP IS ONE OF THE MOST
EGREGIOUS EXAMPLES OF A GROWING
GLOBAL THREAT.
THE FAR RIGHT IS ON THE RISE
AROUND THE WORLD THREATENING OUR
HARD-WON RIGHTS AND FREEDOMS, HE
WROTE.
HE WAS A MAN AT THE TIME WAS AN
INFLUENTIAL MEMBER OF PARLIAMENT
WHEN THE CHINESE PRESIDENT CAME
TO VISIT LONDON.
NOT A PEEP FROM SADIQ KHAN ABOUT
HIM.
AND PRESIDENT XI ONLY HAS, WHAT,
ABOUT 1 MILLION MUSLIMS IN
INTERMENT CAMPS, HE OPPRESSES
CHRISTIANS AND JAILS DISSIDENTS.
THE 25th ANNIVERSARY OF
TIENNAMEN SQUARE IS TODAY.
BUT TRUMP IS THE GLOBAL THREAT
FOR THIS GUY?
OH, MY GOSH.
TRUMP IS NOT JUST HERE TO HAVE A
FANCY DINNER AS HE DID TONIGHT
AT BUCKING HAMM PALACE.
HE'S HERE TO MARK THE 5th
ANNIVERSARY OF THE D-DAY LANDING
AND OUR ENDURING ALLIANCE.
>> THERE ARE OTHER CLOSE ALLIES
COMING FOR THE COMMEMORATION.
A STATE VISIT, A STATE BANQUET
COSTING MILLIONS OF POUNDS.
I DON'T THINK WE SHOULD BE
ROLLING OUT THE RED CARPET.
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT DONALD
TRUMP HAS DONE IN THE LAST TWO
OR THREE YEARS, LONDONERS FIND
OFFENSIVE.
>> WELL, WHEN SOMEONE STRIKES
HIM, TRUMP HITS BACK, EVEN WHEN
IT MAY BE CONSIDERED A
DIPLOMATIC NO-NO TO TO DO SO.
AS THEY LAND IN THE UK, THE THE
PRESIDENT TWEETED, KHAN, WHO BY
ALL ACCOUNTS HAS DONE A TERRIBLE
JOB AS MAYOR OF LONDON, HAS BEEN
NASTY TO THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, BY FAR THE MOST
IMPORTANT ALLY OF THE UNITED
KINGDOM.
HE'S A STONE-COLD LOSER THAT
SHOULD FOCUS ON CRIME IN LONDON,
NOT ME.
THE MEDIA AND THE LEFT FEIGNED
TOTAL OUTRAGE.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP CLEARLY SENT
THAT TWEET JUST SECONDS BEFORE
AIR FORCE ONE TOUCHED DOWN AT
THE AIRPORT KNOWING THAT IT
WOULD CAUSE AN ENORMOUS
FIRESTORM.
>> UNLESS PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
KEPT VERY BUSY IN HIS VISIT, HE
WILL NOT STAY AWAY FROM TWITTER.
>> OF COURSE, THIS PRESIDENT IS
ALWAYS A GREAT DISRUPTER, HE
WASTED NO TIME DISRUPTING THE
SITUATION HERE.
>> PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES GOES TO ENGLAND.
AND BEFORE LANDING INSULTS AND
ATTACKS, ONE OF THE KEY LEE
LEADERS OF THAT COUNTRY
>> Laura: THE OUTGOING FOREIGN
SECRETARY UNDER THERESA MAYE HIT
THE PETTINESS AND
SHORTSIGHTEDNESS OF THE
OPPOSITION PARTY FIGURES HERE.
>> IT'S TOTALLY INAPPROPRIATE
FOR THE LABOUR DEPARTMENT TO BE
BOYCOTTING THIS IMPORTANT VISIT.
THIS IS THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
WE'RE CELEBRATING THE D-DAY
LANDINGS AND WE HAD A MILLION
AMERICAN SERVICEMEN STATIONED IN
THE UK WILLING TO RISK THEIR
LIVES FOR OUR LIBERTY FOR
DEMOCRACY FOR OUR VALUES.
AND I THINK IT SHOULD BE ABOVE
PARTY POLITICS.
I THINK IT'S UTTERLY
DISGRACEFUL.
>> JEREMY CORBIN, THE LABOUR
LEADER, NOT ONLY DID HE NOT GO
TO THE DINNER TONIGHT AT BUCKING
HAMM PALACE BUT HE'S GOING TO
TAKE PART IN THE PROTEST.
HE'S JOINING THE ANTI-TRUMP AND
I WOULD SAY IN MANY WAYS
ANTI-AMERICAN PROTESTS HERE IN
BRITAIN.
CLASSY.
ENGLAND, LET'S FACE IT.
SUCH A BEAUTIFUL PLACE, A
SPECIAL PLACE FOR AMERICANS FOR
SO MANY REASONS, BUT WATCHING
THE ECONOMY HERE, THE BREXIT
POLITICS, AND THE TURMOIL, I
HAVE TO SAY IT MAKES ME
APPRECIATE OUR SYSTEM OF
GOVERNMENT HERE IN THE UNITED
STATES, EVEN WITH ALL OF THE
FLAWS.
YOU KNOW WHY?
BECAUSE IT'S RESPONSIVE COMPARED
TO THE SYSTEM OF GOVERNMENT
HERE.
MUCH MORE RESPONSIVE TO THE WILL
OF THE PEOPLE.
THINK ABOUT THIS.
OVER THE PAST TWO YEARS, THE
DOMINANT PARTIES IN THE UK,
INCLUDING THE CONSERVATIVES,
THEY TRIED TO SWEEP THE CONCERNS
OF THE WORKING CLASS PEOPLE
UNDER THE RUG.
WELL, HOW DID THAT WORK OUT FOR
THEM?
WELL, ENFEEBLED THERESA MAYE
COULDN'T GET A REAL BREXIT DONE
DESPITE THE REFERENDUM MANDATE
FROM HER PEOPLE.
NOW SHE'S DONE.
AND THE BREXIT PARTY FORMED TWO
MONTHS AGO WAS THE TOP VOTE
GETTER IN BRITISH EU ELECTIONS.
THE TIMING OF TRUMP'S APPEARANCE
HERE, WITH ALL OF THE REGAL
TRAFFIC COULD NOT HAVE COME IN A
BETTER TIME.
IT'S A REMINDER OF WHAT'S
POSSIBLE WHEN LEADERS HEED THE
CALL OF THEIR PEOPLE.
STOOD AGAINST THE TIDE OF
CLIMATE HYSTERIA, BURDENSOME
TAXES AND REGULATION, AND
UNRESPONSIVE, INTERNATIONAL
BUREAUCRACIES.
HE'S SUPPORTING BREXIT, NOT
BECAUSE HE WANTS TO MEDDLE IN
THE BRITISH PEOPLE'S AFFAIRS,
BUT BECAUSE HE KNOWS AN
INDEPENDENT BRITAIN, TRULY
INDEPENDENT, WILL BE A BETTER
TRADING PARTNER WITH THE U.S.
AND IN THE END, IT WILL LEAD TO
A STRONGER AMERICA, A STRONGER
BRITAIN, AND A STRONGER
ALLIANCE.
AND I GOT TO TELL YOU, OUTSIDE
OF THE BIG CITIES LIKE LONDON,
NEW YORK, ETC., PEOPLE LIKED THE
FACT THAT TRUMP IS MICKING IT
UP.
-- MIXING IT UP.
HE'S REFUSING TO BE INTIMIDATED
BY THE SO-CALLED "EXPERTS."
THEY'VE HAD ENOUGH OF THE
SMOOTH-TALKING PEOPLE WHO
SCREWED THINGS UP FOR THE
WORKING CLASS PEOPLE IN THE
FIRST PLACE.
AND MAYOR SADIQ KHAN AND OTHERS,
THEY PREFER A DOCILE AMERICAN
PRESIDENT, WHO NODS IN AGREEMENT
WHEN THE U.S. IS GETTING THE
SHORT END OF THE STICK.
WELL, THAT AIN'T TRUMP.
AND THOSE DAYS ARE NOT COMING
BACK ANY TIME SOON.
AND THERE'S A LESSON FOR THE UK
IN THE WORLD TO LEARN FROM THE
TRUMP APPROACH, EVEN THOUGH THEY
MIGHT NOT WANT TO ADMIT IT.
HE PROMISED TO MAKE AMERICA
GREAT AGAIN.
AND THE COUNTRY RESPONDED.
OUR ECONOMY IS NOW THE ENVY OF
THE WORLD.
AND JUST LOOK AT STEEL
MANUFACTURING, OUR STEEL
COMPANIES WERE RAVAGED BY
CHINESE DUMPING PRACTICES, BUT
TRUMP FOUGHT BACK AND SAID NO
MORE.
NOW MANY ARE REVIVED AND
BEGINNING TO THRIVE AGAIN.
YET, HERE IN BRITAIN, THE LAST
MAJOR STEEL COMPANY IS ABOUT TO
GO OUT OF BUSINESS.
THINK ABOUT THIS.
A CENTRAL NATO POWER WILL NO
LONGER BE CAPABLE OF PRODUCING
ITS OWN STEEL?
NO WORRIES, MATE.
BECAUSE THE EXPERTS SAY IT WILL
ALL WORK OUT JUST FINE.
WELL, IT WILL.
WHEN YOU FIGHT BACK AND REBUILD
YOUR OWN INDUSTRIES.
IT MAY BE ONLY JUNE 3, BUT IT
FEELS A LOT LIKE JULY 4 HERE IN
ENGLAND.
TRUMP IS REMINDING OUR COUSINS
THAT A NATION THAT IS NOT TRULY
SOVEREIGN AND FREE WON'T BE A
NATION FOR LONG.
THROUGH STRENGTH AND BROAD-BASED
PROSPERITY WILL ONLY COME TO A
NATION THAT'S INDEPENDENT AND
SOVEREIGN.
AND FOR THOSE WHO BRISTLE AT
TRUMP'S BRASHNESS, I SAY GET
OVER IT.
THE RESISTANCE WON'T ADMIT IT,
BUT HE'S GETTING RESULTS FOR THE
PEOPLE BACK HOME.
AND IF BRITAIN REJECTS THE FALSE